it said kim's new sex tape when you
clicked on it and it's like over my dead
body is this gonna happen to me again
i just want it gone
you know this is not gonna [ __ ] with me
like it's not
so i just want it gone no
no it's not 2007. so ray j's manager is
claiming he has a sex tape of us in
santa barbara and no that's not season
one of keeping up with the kardashians
yep but it is giving us major throwback
vibes that was with my boyfriend of
three years that i was very much in love
with and whatever we did in our private
time
was our private time and never once did
we think that it would get out
during the series premiere of hulu's the
kardashians kim discovers that ray j's
manager claims to have unreleased
footage from her old sex tape with her
ex the one wish star this is supposed to
be unreleased footage from my old sex
tape the last thing that i want as a mom
is for my past to be brought up
20 years later this is some real
embarrassing
and i need to deal with it and i will
deal with it i just cannot believe this
is happening right now
fans of keeping up with the kardashians
will recall that cameras were rolling
back in 2007 fresh off the heels of
kim's sex tape with the singer but i've
already been through this i just like i
don't want to go through this again
please don't cry
i'm sorry
i'm really sorry if i don't know what to
do
flash forward to 2022 and that old tape
has kim crying all over again it's just
annoying you know but kim she snaps out
of it and goes into full lawyer problem
solving boss mode i have four
kids i can't go through this again this
was like 20 years ago
i'm not going to go through this again i
know the right attorneys this time i
know exactly what to do this time i'm
not going to let this happen to me again
so we're going to get on top of this i
have all the time all the money
and all of the resources
to burn them all to the ground don't
mess with kim guys um you know it's
always uncomfortable talking about
myself as a certain way you have a real
insight into what the girls are doing
not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
before you would see little snippets of
something and now i think the episodes
are um you know fuller of content that
shows the whole story and while fans
will just have to wait and see how all
that plays out in episode two chloe
thinks the whole sex tape throwback
moment is a good sign about their new
series didn't we deal with this the
first season of keeping up this is a
good omen you guys what's a good omen
talking about your sex tape in the first
season i feel like we're back to day one
yeah so the kardashians might be back
with a whole new show but it's pretty
clear they're still down to let their
fans in on all the behind the scenes
moments i think for every sister we have
different boundary levels and we all try
to respect that your boundaries are
allowed to change and mine will probably
change later but i think a lot of what
is in the media is sort of things that
we feel we need to film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives especially the
older ones
[Music]
you